les métiers liés au vin sont d'abord
ceux de la production dans les vignes
avec des ouvriers chargés de l'entretien
plantation taille et récolte jusqu'au
chef de culture
il y eut ensuite la transformation ça se
passera dans les caves avec les cavistes
maître de chai ou oenologue et puis
enfin la commercialisation avec l'aide
parfois de négociants ou de courtiers
les formations sont accessibles dès la
classe de 3e pour laisser happer et bep
agricole puis il y à des bac option
vigne et vin des bts après le bac
enfin une formation diplôme national
d'oenologie ça c'est à l'université
après une licence scientifique pour en
savoir plus dans la région je vous
invite à vous rapprocher du lycée
viticole de beaune la viti ou encore des
établissements agricole de davayé en
saône et loire ou de cosne sur loire
dans la nièvre
sans oublier le campus de dijon pour
l'oenologie et puis les lycées hôteliers
comme le castel à dijon pour devenir
sommelier enfin pour vous initier à tous
ses métiers
une bonne façon ça peut être de
participer aux vendanges